trapé g7 l affiche de cette 14e journée
du championnat honneur aux régionales ce
samedi 1er février dans une salle
bouillante chauffée par des centaines de
supporters et trappistes entre dans la
partie de la meilleure des façons
prenant le large rapidement que score à
la pause 18 à 8 ans rentrent à y croire
parce qu'on a mis beaucoup d'intensité
beaucoup beaucoup de rythme
[Musique]
on a aussi remonté les balles poser
l'odieux
des attaques construit de la patience on
a les sites est notre meilleur handball
cette première mi temps
largement au retour des vestiaires les
trappistes reste devant mais connaissent
un passage à vide après la blessure d'un
joueur de l'équipe sur ce contact 15
minutes d'interruption au total le psg
temps de revenir après ce fait de jeu
mini arrivera finalement pas score final
33 à 25 pour les trappistes dans ce
match accroché
il était compliqué c'est vrai on
rencontre une équipe comme du passé
qu'ils étaient fatigués équilibre etc et
reste libre était qu'à l'habitude de
jouer des matches difficiles sont
d'ailleurs partir la semaine dernière
ils s'étaient préparés ils ont battu
l'équipe tt première ex-aequo avec nous
et du coup c'était un match compliqué à
aborder à préparer et mais on a réussi
quand même à rester
régulier tous en france mme anthouard au
classement trappe reste leader avec deux
points d'avancé sur val d'europe
prochain match pour les trappistes le
samedi 29 février sur le terrain de
montfermeil quatrième du classement une
victoire permettrait à trappes
d'envisager une sixième montée
consécutive en cinq ans